Hi YouTube. All the friends. I'm Jet Li. I'm
in Davos. This is the first time for me to
come here and meet a lot of new friends. I
just had the meeting with, I'm very proud
that I met, like brother, Bill Gates. And
why I come here? And I am making a movie for
sure. So I started a foundation called "ONE",
because--. What is "ONE"? People live on the
earth, have different cultures, have different
religion, different languages. But we're human.
That's the first one. Second one; we have
the same value about our family. You know
everybody work very hard. Why? Take care family,
mother, sister, brother, younger brothers.
So I think that's the value of human being
stand. When we talk about philanthropy everybody
talks about money, money, money. If we have
a lot of money we can solve a lot of problems.
I think money is a great thing we have but
on the other hand it's mentally, the heart
and the resource. Also very important, my
belief is if you believe we are this global
family, this earth is our home. Everybody
do a little bit to take care of this home.
Rich people they need to do their job, governments
need to do their jobs. We are just normal
human being , we can do a little bit like
volunteer one hour per month, donate one yuan,
one dollar per month put it on the pool. Take
care of this home, make sure this home is
fresh, healthy; maybe 50 years later give
this home to the next generation. That's what
I called the 21st century philanthropy culture.
That's my belief. Everybody do together. All
the family, now we are the one. We change
together. I hope you join me. "ONE Foundation"
One family. Thank you.